hot breath what is your pre-show routine
so is it you making that grocery list
yeah what is the pre-show routine
um lately it's changed my pre-show
routine
in the past and it depends on what i got
going on am i working on
towards an hour am i like sharpening
something up because then i might have
that list i might have
full index cards like here's my whole
set here's where i think is weak
here is what i think i need to work on
here's what i think is done
even though it usually never is um
but a lot of times lately
and it's because my my special came out
and then i was kind of like
oh now i just want to do comedy for fun
again
like that was such a stressful time of
like
run it run it run it run it run it and
then i was like oh i did it i
achieved my personal goal i made an hour
comedy and i like it
so now because i know a lot of people
are like oh
next hour next hour next hour but to me
that's so mentally draining i was just
like now i get to just
write about whatever it's great
and it's fun and so now
i just kind of talk with my friends
we usually bring like a little speaker
system
even better now i kind of make the clubs
do a playlist of the songs that i want
to listen to
instead of listening to their music you
know because i'm trying to set my tone
and set what we're gonna do for the
evening um so the music's playing me and
my friends are usually just
chatting and having a good time and i'm
laying down
chilling like my my best sets if i'm not
even thinking about it until i get on
breath